hi welcome to this week's episode of
cold fusion
last week we took an interesting dive
into some new research out of stanford
that uses carbon nanotubes to fight
heart disease
it's extremely fascinating and worth a
watch
today we're going to be looking at the
history of adobe adobe is a company that
most of us are familiar with
some people may think that they're a
ripoff and that there's better options
for some of the products that they have
but this always hasn't been the case
from photoshop
to pdfs to premiere pro and illustrator
adobe has changed the computing industry
in a few ways
and all of this came from a backyard
garage and a need to fulfill a gap in
the fledgling computer industry
in this video you'll see adobe's rise to
the top as well as the harrowing story
of how one of their co-founders was
kidnapped at gunpoint
it's interesting so let's get into it
you are watching cold fusion tv
adobe inc was founded in december of
1982
by john warnock and charles geschke the
two of them founded the company in
john's garage
why the name adobe well it's simple
there was a creek by the name of adobe
which ran behind john's house
the logo was designed by marvel warnick
john's wife
and a graphic designer john and charles
established the company after leaving
xerox park
john tried to convince xerox's upper
management to commercialize a key
printing technology that john and
charles had developed
xerox didn't budge so the pair of them
left
as a point of interest if you remember
some previous episodes
xerox park was the research institute
that invented the graphics user
interface
and the desktop computer in modern form
the foundations of which was stolen by
steve jobs to make the macintosh
the printing technology that these two
had created was something called
postscript
even to this day it's the graphics
industry standard for printers
back then postscript was a big deal
printers of the day mainly dot matrix
printers were
capable of printing some crude greyscale
graphics with rows of pixels
but the problem was everything that was
printed had to be fixed to a grid of
dots this meant that the output was
blocky
and they struggled with typography a
major setback for the printer technology
but after some time a newer technology
by the name of laser printing came along
the postscript code became the main
drivers of these new printers
allowing the average consumer to print
detailed images for the first time
the other thing that was true at that
time was absolutely
no graphic artists on the planet used a
computer
and here we were bringing out a product
that was to help graphic artists
and none of them use computers any
sensible marketing person would say
there is no market there
this is the stupidest thing you can
possibly do
uh we did it anyway and over the next
three years
graphic artists said gee the
productivity that i am going to get
out of using this little computer versus
the way i had to do it in the old way
is going to change the way that i work
steve jobs attempted to buy adobe for 5
million
in 1982 but john and charles refused
though their investors urged them to
work something out with jobs
so they agreed to sell him shares worth
nineteen percent of the company
jobs also paid five times the company's
valuation at the time
plus a five-year licensing fee for
postscript in advance
this deal made adobe the first company
in the history of silicon valley to
become profitable in its first year
in 1985 apple computer licensed
postscript for use
in its laser writer printers this helped
spark the desktop publishing revolution
before this digital publishing was
limited to a photo type setter which
were prohibitively expensive
in the range of hundreds of thousands of
dollars xerox made photo typesetters
which explains why upper management
rejected the original idea of postscript
the idea that all you needed for
publishing was a macintosh
and a laserwriter printer was nothing
short of groundbreaking
it replaced the phototype setting
industry in a couple of years and keep
in mind
this was an industry which had been
around since the 1950s
by the mid-80s adobe was booming and
they entered the nasdaq index in august
of 1986.
in 1987 adobe entered the consumer
software market
with illustrator a vector-based drawing
program for the apple macintosh
when i change the eyebrow and move the
curves around
you can see that it's moving on both
images and that you can see the preview
changing as i move the curve
this is a very neat and powerful feature
if i select the
entire eye i can move the eye around
and sort of get a picasso effect in the
image
we can undo any operation with
illustrator
illustrator helped further popularize
postscript enabled laser printers
[Music]
countries of popular belief photoshop
wasn't built in house by adobe
it was actually developed in 1987 by two
brothers
thomas and john knoll thomas knoll
a phd student at the university of
michigan began writing a program on his
macintosh plus to display greyscale
images on a monochrome display
this program caught the attention of his
brother john he recommended that thomas
should turn it into a full-fledged image
editing program
he agreed and took a six-month break
from his studies in 1988
working together with his brother he
would rename the program
image pro but that name was already
taken later that year
thomas would settle in the name
photoshop
during this time his brother john
traveled to silicon valley
he would give demonstrations of the
program to engineers at apple and adobe
they loved it and adobe decided to
purchase the license to distribute the
software in september of 1988
picture may no longer be worth a
thousand words
these days the picture that the camera
takes may well not be the picture that
we end up seeing in newspapers and
magazines
you're a graphic artist yes and yet you
have taken
photography as the medium in which
you've been able to do some of your most
interesting work oh yeah i see the
the computer is a wonderful tool for
graphic artists and i wouldn't live
without it
it's just a must photoshop 1.0
was released on the 19th of february
1990 for macintoshes exclusively
adobe and photoshop quickly became the
industry standard for digital color
editing
it was a significant breakthrough and
here's why
at the time of when photoshop 1.0 was
released
digital retouching cost around 300 per
hour
and that was just for basic photo
retouching the price of the photoshop
software for the macintosh
in 1990 was 895
and with that you could do as much
editing as you wanted
this was no doubt a revolution this time
in digital imagery
[Music]
in the spring of 1991 john warnock
co-founder of adobe
outlined a system that would eventually
become the portable document format
or pdf file format he stated that the
goal of this format
was to quote effectively capture
documents from any
application send electronic versions of
these documents anywhere
and view and print these documents on
any machines
end quote in his writings john imagined
text searching capabilities that could
search for any word or phrase
he imagined that entire libraries could
be archived in electronic form
[Music]
two years later adobe introduced the pdf
along with the acrobat reader
at a windows conference it remained a
proprietary format until it was released
and made open in 2008
pdfs enable one to zoom in on any
document without losing quality and many
other smart features like digital
signatures
things were going great for adobe but as
the company grew in success
so did the secret jealousy
on the morning of may 26 1992 charles
arrives at work and pulls into the adobe
car park in mountain view california
suddenly two men spring out of hiding
and kidnap him at gunpoint
the kidnappers threatened to blow up his
house and hurt his family
charles explains the incident quote i
didn't know how much they knew about me
both my life and my family's life were
going to be in jeopardy
i figured the only thing i could do was
to play it fairly straight with them
they clearly wanted to get money fast if
i didn't cooperate
they'd cut me up into pieces and feed me
to the sharks
end quote later at home nan
charles's wife was worried that her
husband had failed to call
she explains quote i was very afraid
that he'd had a heart attack
i thought it was strange but there had
to be an explanation i never thought of
foul play
at 12 30 pm her phone rang the caller
told her that her husband had been
kidnapped and been taken out of the
state
if she didn't comply with their demands
charles would be cut into a million
pieces
and left at her doorstep he demanded
that she come up with 650
000 and also to keep silent because she
was being followed and watched
frightened to call from the house she
decided to use a public pay phone and
warn the adobe ceo
john warnock in case he was next
she also called two stock brokers and
demanded that they liquidate stocks into
a hundred dollar bills within 10 days
she would work in secret to inform
others and switched cars and changed
clothes
sometimes going on foot because she was
sure that she was being watched
when john warnock heard the news he
argued with his wife over what action to
take
marva his wife strongly believed that
they should call the fbi
but jon thought that this would be the
ultimate betrayal if something was to
happen to charles
besides being good friends john and
charles had worked together for more
than 16 years
he eventually decided to call the fbi
as the evening progressed the captors
fantasized out loud about what kind of
cars they would buy once they got the
money
and over the next few days the captors
taunted charles
after four grueling days and working and
discussing with the families
the fbi had their plan charles's
daughter
kathy would negotiate with the
kidnappers she was going to wear a wire
and a bulletproof vest to drive the
money to the captors
she cried the whole way with an fbi
agent hidden in the backseat
relaying instructions to other agents in
undercover cars
after a four-day hostage situation on
may the 31st
the fbi burst into where charles was
being held and he was finally rescued
[Music]
the two kidnappers 25 and 26 years of
age were eventually sentenced to life
terms in a state prison
charles was lucky the following month in
new jersey
authorities discovered the body of an
exxon executive
abducted a month before charles he died
a brutal death in captivity
after struggling with his kidnappers
after the horrifying incident charles
and his family decided to continue
living life as normal they didn't flee
or hire bodyguards
they didn't want to be robbed of a
normal life and say what you will
but i think that shows great strength on
their part
for adobe as a company the show had to
go on
while the dust was settling from this
event in 1993
photoshop was ported to microsoft
windows and now
adobe had truly entered the mass market
photo had been conquered but now it was
time for video
in december of 1991 adobe released
premiere
an editing software which cnn was an
early adopter of
adobe would rename this to premiere pro
in 2003
today the software has been used to edit
feature films such as deadpool
and this episode itself is edited in
both premiere pro and after effects
adobe after effects was originally
created by a team at the group
company of science and art in january of
1993
it would be acquired by adobe in 1994.
in the new century adobe grew their
acquisitions at a record pace
with their purchase of cool edit pro now
adobe audition
and their acquisition of their main
rival macromedia
adding cold fusion flash and much more
adobe's 2010 was marked by the
continuing back and forth arguments
between apple and them
regarding support of adobe flash on the
iphone ipad and other products
in april of 2010 steve jobs published a
post titled
thoughts on flash here he outlined his
thoughts on the technology and the rise
of html5
he cited that rapid energy consumption
poor performance on mobile devices
abysmal security and a lack of touch
support were reasons to dump flash
in the end steve jobs won and in
november of 2011
adobe announced that they would cease
development of flash for mobile devices
instead they would focus on html5
the next year was no better for adobe
in 2012 40 million sets of payment card
information was compromised by a hack on
adobe
a crippling taint for the company's
image but despite this
from 1995 to 2013 14 ranked adobe as
quote
an outstanding place to work in october
of 2018
adobe officially changed its name from
adobe systems incorporated to adobe inc
in 2019 the company seriously started
its push into mobile by releasing
photoshop
illustrator and rush for the ipad
last year the company made 11 billion
dollars in revenue
and currently has about 20 000 employees
adobe has been criticized for its
pricing practices with retail prices
being up to twice as much in non-us
countries
adobe's reader and flash programs were
included in a list
of the 10 most hated programs of all
time by techradar
for me and many other video producers
i'm sure you've had your fair share of
nonsensical errors from time to time
on adobe premiere pro and after effects
sometimes it just flat out goes crazy
for no reason
and you must either laugh or cry after
using a lot of different other creative
software like ableton for example
you just have to wonder why they can't
design their production flow
smoothly where things just make sense
without having to dig through
illogical menus regardless of all of
this there's no doubt that adobe
software has made a major impact on all
of our lives
in one way or another from pdfs to
photoshop
to video editing to being the first to
usher in the era of digital desktop
publishing
in 2009 charles won the 2008
national medal of technology and in 2010
both john and charles received the
marconi prize
the marconi prize is considered the
highest honor for contributions in
information science and communications
both founders now live largely out of
the public eye these days
but there's no doubt that they've
changed the world i also don't doubt
that both of them would have a lifelong
bond
after building such an influential
company and going through the events of
the kidnapping of charles
but with that that ends the story of
adobe
it's an interesting story mainly about
being in the right place at the right
time
but also seeing potential and
understanding the future
of a new and developing market so for
those of you still watching
i'm interested to know if you use an
adobe product
anyway thanks for watching my name is
dagogo and you've been watching cold
fusion if you want to see anything on
science technology business or history
definitely subscribe to cold fusion
you'll see a lot of cool stuff on here
next week we're going to take an
interesting look at an ai that can write
anything
from journal articles to computer code
it's interesting
so stay tuned for that one if any of you
want to support the channel and get some
cold fusion merge
the standard lion is still available
alright i'll see you again next week
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's me thinking
[Music]